[Music]
Martellus Bennett recently told bleacher
report regarding hatreds coach Bill
Belichick bill always had bad plays a
day and he's just calling out Tom you
know he's like we have quarterbacks that
can't make throws I've never seen
coaches really call the quarterbacks out
in group meetings the next day we go 33
for 33 or something like that at
practice and from then I was just like
oh we're gonna be great
and look Bill Belichick calls out Tom
Brady that's what he does there are no
sacred cows in New England and Belichick
sets the tone by always calling out his
quarterback so today's draft
quarterbacks currently NFL that would
benefit from the Bill Belichick
treatment of always being called out in
the hopes that they would reach and
sustain their full potential big cat you
have the honors heads or tails in the
draft now I know how this goes you'll
win the toss and refer to me but let's
go heads or tails
alright tails yeah it's already been
heads this month the heads quota has
been filled
there's tails all right I'll pick first
I'm gonna go with the easy first
selection how about Ben Roethlisberger
if you don't think part of this last
year with the Steelers with Le'Veon Bell
with Antonio Brown with the
disappointment of not making the
playoffs some of the blame has to be at
Big Ben's feet and I'm guessing that
none of the blame is at Big Ben's feet
when it comes to the locker room you've
heard the rumblings he's a phenomenal
Hall of Fame quarterback but is he held
to the same accountable level that the
rest of the team is I think the answer
is no it would probably go a long way if
Mike Tomlin evened it out a little and
said Ben you two need to step up your
game and play better if we want to get
back to the playoffs I agree with you
but here's the problem it happened 10 11
days ago when they gave him a new
contract with 68 million in new money
when they gave him a signing bonus of 37
and a half million they're gonna pay him
45 million this year this is the
validation Ben just keep being Ben and I
suggested earlier this week somewhere
that did they give him all that money
just because they felt compelled to let
the world know they still believe in
this guy like it was
there was there a jerk premium that that
the Steelers had to pay to
Roethlisberger to push back against the
narrative that he's a bad teammate and a
bad leader so that new contract tells us
all we need to know they're gonna let
Ben continue to be bent but it would be
nice if my Tomlin called him out maybe
in a practice probably go a long way
he's my number one pick I don't disagree
with you that he is he's the guy that
that I would have considered after the
one who I think really should be the
first one on the list and that is
Vikings quarterback Kirk Cousins who's
gotten paid but he hasn't lived up to it
and there's an issue in primetime and I
know there are plenty of other problems
with the Vikings offensive line this
that new thing they are gradually and
systematically crossing off the list of
excuse items for Kirk Cousins this year
no excuses this year in the second year
that three are 84 million dollar
contract it's on cousins to step up in
games that count I know they all count
but the big games the night games the
games that you look at and you circle
when the schedule comes out and say this
is one that's gonna require everything
that we can muster they had an
opportunity on a Monday night in Seattle
their defense was playing great against
the Seahawks shutting down Russell
Wilson the offense couldn't do crap at
some point it falls back on the
quarterback in Mike Zimmer the head
coach he's a Bill Belichick Bill
Parcells disciple just like Bill
Belichick so there's that common link
there and Zimmer is not afraid to speak
his mind I think this is the year that
Zimmer needs to be more aggressive
telling Kirk Cousins how he needs to be
and when he's not doing what he needs to
do all right you obviously think in the
back of your mind like hey man maybe if
someone just lit a fire under Kirk
Cousins but he would be a good
quarterback not gonna happen Mike sorry
I'm yeah I think I think if throughout
my entire brain yeah it's not gonna
happen is no hidden agenda here I'm
trying to do for Cousins what somebody
needs to do for him in the locker room
come on Kirk step it up yeah he's
calling them out right now all right my
second picks also easy I'm surprised you
didn't go here another place where
there's rumblings will stay in
Pennsylvania I'm going with the
Philadelphia Eagles I'm going with
Carson Wentz there were rumblings about
Carson thinks that he is you know the
best player on the team
it was Nick Foles locker room I think he
has to earn back a little bit of trust I
know that some of the players came out
and said you know this is hogwash this
isn't real but I'm a big time where
there's smoke there's fire when it comes
to these stories and what Nick Foles did
with the team winning the Super Bowl
taking him on that run again last year
Carson Wentz has to rebuild some stuff
there and I think getting called out and
being held accountable will go a long
way to bringing the team back together
now they're a playoff team but you know
what I'm saying the Carson Wentz
probably has to kind of elevate himself
as a team leader now that Nick Foles is
gone well two of the flaws that the
Eagles have and I agree with you they
need to call him out one is they need to
call him out when it comes to putting
himself in harm's way he has to adjust
his playing style so he doesn't get
injured in December and they have to
hope that the backup can come in and
save the season and secondly and and
this is a Chris Sims take that we keep
coming back to because I think it's
accurate the coaching staff gets so
smitten with what
Carson Wentz can do they get away from
what they need to do to be an effective
offense drive in and drive out and I
think part of that is coaching
themselves but also coaching Carson
Wentz to stick with the things that they
know will work and not abandon and
improvise and do things that fascinate
the coaches but also frustrate with the
team's trying to do so I like that one
as well
but I'm surprised this guy's still on
the board I I my emotion took over with
Kirk Cousins my brain is now kicking in
eventually Aaron Rodgers I mean my god
we've seen the story we know that when
we know that he needs that that push
that shove that he needs to be nudged to
be better than he is and and you know
he's been he's been a guy that they
tiptoe around and they've done it for a
decade now just think of how great he
could be if you could get through to him
and push his buttons and call him out
and and make him be an even better
quarterback than what he's been and what
happens if you don't it goes completely
the other way
that's a terrible pick Mike you call it
Aaron Rodgers neat about Aaron Rodgers
held a grudge against Mike McCarthy for
ten plus years even after they won a
Super Bowl because Mike McCarthy passed
on him in the draft do you really want
to walk in the first day and be like
Rogers I'm gonna start I'm gonna start a
little feud with you I'm gonna call you
out and have him go back to grudge Aaron
Rodgers I think it's the other way you
gonna challenge it mentally you don't
call them out you say look you're the
best player in the NFL if you do what I
say and if you follow what we do and
we're gonna revolutionize this playbook
and we're gonna be an explosive offense
dynamic all these things you call it
Aaron Rodgers in front of the team I
guarantee you that back that backfires
big picture the Packers it's not working
it hasn't been working even with the
presence of Aaron Rodgers this is like
the guy who shows up for the first day
of prison like it's the first day of
school or something no dude you're wrong
and the biggest baddest guy and you kick
his ass yeah you're gonna get killed
you're but you know what either die
faster you die slow either way you're
gonna die so you may as well turn things
around in Green Bay while you can he
definitely needs to be coached
aggressively and you know what at some
point grow up man
what do you you know I mean I hold
grudges too but you get past him at some
point you're an adult if you're holding
my grudge from 2005 there's something
wrong with you what that was that was
the understatement of the year of the
millennium Mike Florio I hold grudges -
yeah you think you're the journalist
gonna make one of these days you Palmer
you're gonna how I'm gonna get yeah I'm
gonna get on your grudge list right now
my third pick is Michael's Florio the QB
of this show the QB of pro football talk
terrible question of Randy Moss did no
research for the Kentucky better I'm
calling you out right now look at all
the notes I take I take notes for this
show that sends me everything and I take
notes for this show and I prepare for
this show and then I have to sit here
and listen to you ask Randy Moss oh
what's the weather gonna be like on
Saturday Randy I'm calling you out but
but you know we have viewers out there
we have listeners out there who may not
know we just assume that they know the
weather is gonna be bad
so I will okay I will teach you how to
do it because we're calling you out
right here Randy great to have you on
the weather's gonna be terrible on
today in Louisville talk to us about how
that affects the horses when they're
trying to run through the mud I still
get a big J school I stand corrected all
right Matthew Stafford for me as the
third pick I wanted to go Jared Goff
just to stick it to you a little bit but
you know Matt Matthew Stafford I think a
guy who not through his own fault he's
the one that had to endure a decade of
bad coaching in Detroit and now that
Matt Patricia's there right off of the
Bill Belichick tree he's gonna try to
give Matthew Stafford some of that Tom
Brady treatment and I think Stafford
would benefit from it you know that the
guy is immensely talented but he's never
been coached the way he needs to be he's
never embraced the things that he needs
to embrace because there's never been
anyone there to tell him how he needs to
embrace the job how he needs to grow
into that role of a leader he's still
got the potential to have a Hall of Fame
career he's still got the potential to
turn this thing around it sounds crazy
as I say it but they have the potential
to do it and one of the ways to do it is
to get through to Matthew Stafford and
get in to embrace everything about the
job leadership accountability it's not
just go out and throw a football with so
much bigger than that and maybe Matt
Patricia can draw it out of him that's a
good pick a couple other names I'll
throw out there Jameis Winston another
guy obviously was kind of given the
world said you are the next franchise
quarterback it hasn't worked out with
Bruce Arians down there I think this is
a big year for him calling him out will
go a long way criticizing him especially
coming from a guy like Bruce Arians who
everyone should respect in the room and
know that he's got you know the QB
whisper or tag the last one I had Eli
Manning because what has happened this
offseason is the Giants have been an
absolute mess you don't think the guys
in that locker room like why did we
trade our best player in Odell Beckham
why did we draft Daniel Jones with a six
pick where everyone else had him as a
late first round or second round or
talent everyone is saying you know
whispering around saying look this is
Eli's team and he has ownership and the
coaching staff in the palm of his hand
so I think it would go a long way if Pat
Shermer on day one calls out Eli and
said you have to be better and we need
you to be bad
for us to win football games two quick
points on the way out first
I think Jared Goff needs to get called
out I think there's too much tiptoeing
on eggshells around him I think he could
be better or if he's reached his maximum
they need to think about their
alternatives and secondly on on Bruce
Arians and Jameis Winston Area's was on
ESPN over the weekend and he's already
calling Jameis Winston out publicly they
said what is Winston needs to do he said
quit throwing at the other team that's
Bruce Arians and Winston's either gonna
reach his maximum or he's going to
shatter under Bruce Arians we'll find
out what happens with them and the rest
of the quarterbacks who need some
aggressive coaching this year I guess
including me that is weird man to see
that there I don't believe that that is
the only way I'm ever ending up on that
list by doing bad research for a horse
racing interview and needing to be
coached by big cat about you know
knowing the weather report at Churchill
down
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports